[موسيقى]
النظام لراني الراهن كما نراها مزعزع جدا
بسبب المظاهرات المستمره منذ شهور والتي
يقودها جيل جديد واعتقد ان هنا ايضا هناك
انتقال للاجيال وهو امر يجب اخذه في
الحسبان بشكل عام رغبه فرنسا دائما وابدا
كانت القول ان ايران موجوده هي موجوده في
المنطقه ويجب ان يكون لديها مكان او مكان
يمكن ان يتم التشاور
بشانه مع الدول المجاوره نحن كنا مهتمين
بان ايران عبر ربما وسطات او او
مثل حزب الله والحوثيين يحاولوا اتموقع في
مناطق اخرى لحمايه نفسه وكذلك زعزعه بلدان
الاقليم هذا امر غير مقبول
[موسيقى]
مرارا بان يندمج الايرانيون في المجتمع
الدولي واكد على ذلك ولكن ربما يحتاجون
لمكانهم المناسب مع مراعاه بان الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه تريد ان تتمدد وهذا ايضا عنصر
يجب اخذه في موازين القوه التي نريدها
ولكن الفكره هي ان يتم تجنب وكان هذا هو
هدف
الاتفاق النووي الذي للاسف انسحب منه
الامريكيون اذا الهدف هو منح ايران
مكاننا او مكانتها
وان تبقى ايران عند مستوى معين في المجال
النووي ان تستفيد من الاستثمارات ثم تندمج
في المجتمع الدولي
[موسيقى]